para todo el número real x x entre
corchetes define al mayor entero menor o
igual a x es conocida como la función
mayor entero sea s una función real
evaluada definida en el intervalo de
menos 10 a 10 incluyendo los extremos se
define como x - el mayor entero de x si
el mayor entero de x es impar y uno más
el mayor entero de x men x si el mayor
entero de x es paz luego el valor de pi
cuadrada sobre 10 por la integral de
menos 10 a 10s de x coseno de px de x es
bueno antes de intentar resolver la
integral hay que ver si podemos
visualizar la función fx muy bien
visualicemos la función fx definida de
esa manera aquí voy a dibujar mi eje de
las x y aquí voy a dibujar mi eje de las
muy bien ya tengo mis ejes ahora aquí
está el punto cero entonces ponemos el
cero aquí tengo el 1 aquí x2 x igual a 3
también tengo los negativos x igual a
menos 1 x igual a menos 2 y así puedo
seguir pensemos en cómo se ve dicha
función esperemos encontrar un patrón ya
que la función cambiado para impar muy
bien iniciemos en el intervalo del 0 al
1 quién es el mayor entero en el
intervalo del 0 al 1 lo que estoy
haciendo es lo siguiente estoy tomándome
a 0 hasta llegar al 1 es decir todos los
que estén bajo el 1 entonces el mayor
entero
es cero ya que si tengo 0.5 el mayor
interés cero es todos los que están bajo
el 1 ahora bien del 1 al 2 cuál es el
mayor entero ah bueno pues del 1 al 2 el
mayor entero es 1 ya que si tengo 1.5 el
mayor entero es 1 si yo tengo unos
puntos 9 el mayor entero es uno análogo
para el intervalo de 2 a 3 del 2 al 3 el
mayor entero es 2 si yo tengo 2.4 el
mayor interés 2 si yo tengo 2.9 el mayor
entre los dos ya con esto intentemos
dibujar la gráfica entonces en el
intervalo del 0 al 1
el mayor entero es 0 lo podemos
considerar par así por alternancia
tenemos que el 0 es paz el lunes impar
el 2 es paz
este es impar y así entonces tenemos
este caso donde el mayor entero es paz
ahora bien aquí uno más el mayor entero
de x x estamos trabajando sobre el
intervalo del 0 al 1 y en el intervalo
del 0 al 1
el mayor entero es 0 por lo tanto nos
queda aquí la función fx es igual a 1 -
x aquí tengo uno y entonces la función
baja de esta manera entonces se ve así
en el intervalo del 0 al 1 ahora
pensemos en el intervalo 12 en el
intervalo 12 es decir tomando al 1 pero
no tomando el 2 lo que tenemos es que el
mayor entero es 1 por lo tanto tenemos
en este caso el mayor entero es impar
entonces trabajamos aquí x - el mayor
entero de x que en este caso es 1
tenemos entonces la gráfica de x menos 1
y la gráfica de x menos 1 se ve así
cuando x es 1 tenemos cero y cuando x es
2 tenemos 1 por lo tanto sube de esta
manera y así tenemos que esto es la
gráfica de x
1 y esta es la gráfica de 1 - x y
continuamos de 2 a 3
el mayor entero es 2 entonces vemos este
caso por lo tanto 1 + 23 menos x cuando
x estos tenemos entonces tres menos 2 es
1 y cuando x es 3 tenemos 3 menos 30 por
lo tanto la gráfica baja de esta manera
oscila nuevamente hacia abajo ahora sí
creo ya tenemos una buena apreciación de
cómo se ve la gráfica de nuestra función
así saltarina va a bajar subir bajar
subir con la pendiente positiva negativa
positiva negativa y así va a seguir
sucesivamente puedes intentarlo con
otros intervalos es claro que ese es el
patrón de la función ahora queremos
evaluar la integral de menos 10 a 10 de
esta función por el coseno de px y ver
si coseno de pie x es periódica y claro
que es periódica ahora también
intentemos simplificar la integral de
tal
que no tengamos que evaluarla en todo
este periodo
hagámosla una integral más simple
evaluamos la función en x igual a cero
tenemos coste no de tipo cero que es
coseno de cero y coseno de cero es 1
entonces ponemos uno ahora bien en x
igual a 1 tenemos coseno de iu por 1
entonces con seno del consejo de pi y
evaluando es igual a menos 1 entonces
ponemos aquí menos 1 en x igualados
tenemos coseno de 2 pi
nuevamente es 1 y claro en x igual a un
medio tenemos que coseno de pime dioses
0 por lo tanto tenemos aquí 0 y 0
entonces nuestra función baja de la
siguiente manera
cruzando x igual a un medio
y sube nuevamente y baja otra vez y
entonces ves que también es periódica
ahora si quisiéramos averiguar la
integral del producto de estas dos
funciones periódicas evaluadas desde
menos 10 a 10 creen que lo podemos
simplificar creen que podemos
simplificar dicha integral sí sí podemos
sí porque para simplificarnos la
existencia lo que hacemos es por ejemplo
tomar el intervalo del 0 al 1 y aquí
tomamos el producto de las dos funciones
de kossen o pi x por 1 - x y vemos cuál
es el área bajo la curva ahora en el
siguiente intervalo del intervalo 12 si
tomamos el producto de estas dos
funciones esta x está tenemos la misma
área entonces aquí lo que estamos viendo
es que si tomamos del intervalo 0 1 y
después del 1 al 2 y a estas dos
funciones las ponemos una sobre la otra
bajo este eje de simetría son totalmente
iguales
simétricas entonces cuando tengamos el
producto de las dos funciones bajo la
curva vamos a tener la misma área
también del 2 al 3 si observas tenemos
la misma función que del 0 al 1 entonces
esto se repite ahora bien ambas
funciones se ven idénticas bajo ese
intervalo pero también sería lo mismo
que del intervalo 1 al 2 por la simetría
entonces el producto de estas dos sobre
este eje ellas lanzan el mismo valor de
la integral en esos intervalos ahora
bien queremos reescribir esto de aquí
evaluamos queremos evaluar si cuadradas
sobre 10 por la integral de menos 10 a
10 de fx coseno de pi x ahora usando
esta lógica lo que tenemos es que esto
es igual
y cuadrada y cuadrada sobre 10 por la
integral pero del 0 al 1 del producto de
estas dos funciones entonces del 0 al 1
tenemos que la integral de menos 10 a 10
es el 01 pero 20 veces entonces tenemos
el intervalo por 20 veces de la integral
del 0 al 1 de fm x
coseno de px de x y quiero asegurarme
que esto quede claro porque esto es
realmente la parte difícil del problema
solo darse cuenta que la integral en
este intervalo del 0 al 1 es una
veinteava parte de toda la integral y se
repite para cada intervalo para cada
intervalo vale lo mismo del 1 al 2
también es la misma integral y así
entonces en lugar de hacer la integral
de menos 10 a 10 vamos a hacer 20 veces
la integral del intervalo 01 de menos 10
a 10 hay una diferencia de 20 entonces
estamos multiplicando aquí por 20 y esto
nos simplifica mucho primeramente aquí
20 entre 10 es 2
entonces tenemos dos pies cuadrados
esto es aparte por la integral del 0 al
1 pero de 0 a 1 que ssd x a bueno de 0 a
1 f x es 1 x entonces fx es 1 x del 0 al
1 por el coste no de px de x y ahora
sólo nos queda evaluar 2 pie al cuadrado
por esta integral ahora bien esto de
aquí 1 - x por el coste no de px
es lo mismo que cocinó de pi x - x
coseno de px
ahora vamos a tomar la anti derivada
enfoquemos en tomar la anti derivada
bueno en este caso en el coste no pi x
es bastante sencillo entonces enfoquemos
en este otro caso la anti derivada la
anti derivada de x coseno de pi x aquí
lo que depende a tu mente es a bueno
pues no está tan sencillo este asunto
pero si yo me puedo tomar la derivada de
x eso simplifica mucho las cosas y
tomarse la anti derivada de coseno de px
podemos hacerlo sin hacer las cosas más
difíciles entonces que viene a la mente
pues integración por partes y que no
dice la integración por partes la
integración por parte nos dice que la
integral de un bebé es igual a v menos
la integral de bdv y lo vamos a aplicar
aquí ahora ya ha hecho pruebas y
ejemplos donde uso esto y te muestro qué
significa pero vamos a aplicarlo aquí y
en general vamos a tomar la derivada de
lo que sea esta cosa y lo que queremos
es que use algo sencillo cuando me tomo
la derivada y de
voy a tomar la anti derivada de debe
entonces queremos algo que no sea tan
complicado cuando me tomo la anti
derivada y lo que es más sencillo cuando
me tomo la derivada es x entonces pongo
o igual a x luego claramente desigualdad
de x vvx es igual a 1 entonces
desigualdad de x
ahora bien luego debe ser a el resto
esto de aquí entonces debe es igual al
coseno de px coseno de px de x entonces
la anti derivada de eso es justamente be
es la anti derivada de esto con respecto
a x y esto es igual a 1 sobre pi seno de
px y es verdad si me tomo la derivada de
esto y de lo de adentro lo que obtengo
spears y uno sobre pib por pi se cancela
entonces la derivada de seno de pie x es
coseno de px entonces ya tenemos nuestro
nuestro b por lo tanto esta integral va
a ser igual
por ver qué es x por 1 sobre ti entonces
x sobre seno de iu x menos - la integral
- la integral de b pero es igual a 1
sobre pisen de px por d pero de u s x
entonces por de x y esto ya sale
inmediato la anti derivada de seno de px
es 1 sobre pío menos uno sobre pi coseno
de px y puedes tomar la derivada para
verificar usando sustitución ahora bien
en esta expresión de aquí esto es igual
a equis
x sobre seno de ti x menos esta
expresión de acá ahora en esta expresión
la anti derivada de seno de pi x es
menos 1 sobre pib coseno de pie x
entonces los menos se cancelan y tenemos
más uno sobre pi por 1 sobre pies 1
sobre pi cuadrada coseno de pío x y esa
es la anti derivada de esto la puedes
verificar derivando costero de px
es menos pi seno de px un peak se
cancela obtenemos un signo negativo y
tenemos seno de px entonces esto es la
derivada de esto entonces lo que
queremos es la anti derivada de esto
ahora es lo que nos interesa del 0 al 1
del 0 al 1 de x la anti derivada de este
primer término coseno de px sale
inmediata de hecho ya la hicimos es 1
sobre el seno de pío x
y ahora este segundo término es lo que
acabamos de hacer aquí entonces con un
siglo menos lo estamos restando ponemos
menos x sobre bi xenón de pie x menos 1
sobre pi cuadrada coseno de pi x es la
anti derivada entonces estamos tomando
la integral definida del 0 al 1 entonces
evaluamos del 0 al 1 y tampoco olvidemos
el 2 y cuadradas vamos a multiplicar por
eso entonces ponemos aquí 2 y cuadrada
entonces hay que evaluar primeramente
evaluamos con 11 sobre pi seno de pi por
10 de pies cero entonces
0 - 1 sobre pi seno de iu por 1
nuevamente tenemos 0
y menos 1 sobre pi cuadradas coseno depp
y por unos coseno de pi por 1 es cocinar
ep menos uno entonces tenemos menos por
menos + + 1 sobre pi cuadrada y eso es
evaluado en 1 ahora veamos evaluado en 0
- evaluado en cero tenemos seno de cero
es 0 - aquí x es igual a cero entonces
claramente 0 y seno de 0 es cero menos
12 90 es 1 entonces nos queda uno sobre
pi cuadrada entonces ponemos 1 sobre pi
cuadrada y ahora bien entonces aquí
vamos a multiplicar por un menos tenemos
entonces más menos más más y nos queda
uno sobre pi cuadrada más uno sobre pi
cuadrada que es igual a 2 sobre pi
cuadrada entonces 2 sobre pi cuadrada
y eso es lo que obtenemos de evaluar en
esa expresión ahora no olvidemos
multiplicarlo por el 2 y cuadradas todo
ese término se multiplica por 2 y
cuadradas entonces por 2 y cuadradas que
es justo lo que tenemos frente a la
integral adiós a los pi cuadrados 2 x 2
es 4 entonces todo esto que parecía
bastante complicado se resume
simplemente a 4